the Joe Rogan experience speedo don't
seem like the comfort move seems like a
bad decision yeah that's not someone who
really wants a dick to be caressed and
cradled he does it like you're punishing
your deck like you [ __ ] it's like
you're it's like a tent in a storm
you know nailing it down punishing it or
showing it off right yeah you've got a
hog yeah getting a penis enlargement by
speedos
yeah just put uh just take your
circumcised dick and pull it all the way
down so it's a full erection Aaron and
then put a ring a rubber ring on the
base the balls to contract all the blood
or constrict all the blood yeah that's a
weird thing that someone figured that
out right [ __ ] rings
yeah hmm how do I uh how do I stay hard
here it's gotta be a way to put a rubber
band phrase your dick Berggren yeah
yikes
yeah that's a one thing that if they do
ever come out I used to have a bit about
that if they ever come up with a pill
for how to like a boner or a dick
enlargement pill that actually works
it'd be 30 seconds later the first do
would die of an overdose all right yeah
just take one you're gonna find out how
many give me a stroke one Jesus Christ
yeah I had a whole there was a whole
sequence where women would evolve
because people just are sex but the
dicks would get bigger in the rain would
develop these flying squirrel Missy's
well they would just jump off the cliffs
to get away from dudes who were chasing
after them with their big dicks and
shopping carts and fell in it grow wings
why women growing wings just a Fed so
people could mate yeah yeah if you could
grow a big like have you ever watched a
porn and said that's just too much yeah
yeah yeah so comes a certain point time
we're like how big do you want your arms
right yes you want a big arm I do you
want to arm where the bicep touches your
fingers when you go like this all right
do you want that oh you can't even move
that's crazy it's too big
yeah right that means it means you can
never do this you do anything like this
now you probably can't even walk yeah
you're just too heavy
you're probably waddling everywhere you
go you weigh 600 pounds and you're 5/8
how the [ __ ] you're doing that right
there's a size too much you can get too
much
yeah can get too much dick who get a
body dysmorphia with their breasts ah
yes girls go crazy like they have triple
E's and they need them an F they get
nuts it's crazy they don't see it like
the way you're saying it that's how it
happens with anorexics
bodybuilders yeah yeah and it's goddamn
bananas it is the dick thing is a it's a
weird one right yeah that will
definitely it's definitely gonna happen
since women overdo it with the breast
size and like you say they can't see how
weird it looks yeah it's a normal thing
with humans yeah have you seen those
guys that inject their muscles with oil
it makes their muscles swell up like
balloons it looks so fake but they don't
see it there its body dysmorphia yeah I
think that an anorexic gets when they
don't recognize that they're there look
like a skeleton
when was at the airport in Vegas and
we're waiting for your pool thing there
was this chick and she had like a weird
but poor girl and it wasn't real and you
could tell only she didn't know that it
didn't look real she probably thought it
looked amazing right yeah she was
walking around like but never your
confidence yeah at that bit yeah yeah
people get strange because the butt
thing is treated differently than the
boob thing mmm like a woman with really
large fake breasts is still hot yes but
a woman with really large fake butts
like come on yeah that comes off crazy
yeah yes and fake lips it's another one
that's crazy too
yeah yeah we have rules it's weird yeah
fake lips it's like what am I supposed
to do just pretend this is not happening
in front of me right now well it's also
with [ __ ] with your apparently we have
and when we see a certain person when
see people's faces we have an
expectation to where things are going to
be and based on where things are all
right that's all like the Fibonacci
sequence like the golden ratio the way
your face is designed like like Ari
Shaffir
if Ari should figure out a tiny nose
he'd be like what is wrong with us
face it big nose this is like how your
that style of face yeah it's supposed to
come with that style of nose
yeah right if it doesn't it's weird but
then you look at a guy like Greg
Fitzsimmons has a little nose mm-hmm you
know if he had already snows you be like
what is that nose doing on your face
right crazy it's like you [ __ ] with that
when you do something to make something
bigger or wider or you know with your
face you know people get tattoos and
different things like suppose people
start enlarge in areas of their face you
just I get my ears bigger nose is what
if big ears come in the face Dumbo ears
well how about those holes where people
stretch they do their eyes and they pull
their [ __ ] ear hole out to put that
earring hole at the bottom make it giant
yeah like a hoop that's bananas
yeah like what are you doing to your
ears yeah like I don't want to [ __ ] up
the chance of me not being able to hear
some [ __ ] I don't think it does work
it's just I'm not doing anything
personally that's close to anything that
I need yeah I need this for what I need
this for I'm not gonna do anything to it
that might jeopardize it in any way I
always feel like that about cauliflower
here - mmm that go - all the years that
I did you just - I don't have
cauliflower here because I always worry
your guards right it's like if you [ __ ]
with the shape of your ear it [ __ ] with
the way sound goes in there okay like
take your ear and then talk go blah blah
blah now put your tip the tips of your
fingers on the top of your ear and then
fold them down la la la la la la la
it changes the way sounds are changes
sound like this helps this sound
these are speakers these are Bose right
you know that yeah you [ __ ] with your
bow bows it's the shape nature figured
out a shape to collect all that sound
and and get it inside your ear holes
yeah but when you're outside of your
ears like a rock like a lot of these
wrestlers and jiu-jitsu guys they have
it's all calcified so that with that
cauliflower Iran if you're a touch -
cauliflower you know it's like a rock
under the surface very calcium rock
that's what it's like because the it's
what it is is the break in the skin
it swells up because it bleeds and then
that blood calcifies and hardens and the
only way to fix my friend Brett had his
fixed mm-hmm
Brent yeah Brent my friend Brent had to
fix it they had to cut his ear like a
fish they had a fillet and then they got
to open it up and scrape out all the the
hard tissue and then sew it back up
together and he couldn't do Jiu Jitsu
forever because if he did Jiu Jitsu
again after the operation it would break
open and start bleeding again Pam yeah I
was looking for a picture where a guy
gets this part I've seen people with a
plug and a hole on the inner part here
oh I've seen that yeah but this guy took
it like that definitely [ __ ] with his
hearing a hundred percent oh yeah he's
got a giant gage hole in the bottom and
a medium gauge hole in the top and then
big ones on his nostrils where his
nostrils he has like the bottom hole
where his nostrils are and then above
the nostrils get two huge holes we could
see the septum he opened up the side of
his nostril quarter-sized hole easily I
can't say that dudes real happy
I just don't see it I don't understand
that look but hey man what are you gonna
do
[Applause]